Này mới làm tháng buổi tại lạng sơn, vì phên bộ chiến trị bí thư Trung mương đàn trường bán tổ chức Trung
Lề bình thương đã trau quyết định của bộ chiến trị, đều động xí tiến ông khoảng khóc khánh,
miếng bí thư tình quy xuân lá, giữ trước bí thư tình quy lạng sơn, nhận kế hay những khổ trong ai nhằm
hành in cũng sẽ mang buổi, thay trở ông khoảng văn nghiệp, đều khổ chánh trị đều động
xí định làm bí thư tình quy xuân lá, chú mừng tất bí thư tình quy lạng sơn, trường bán tổ chức Trung
lề bình thương giản mạnh, đồng chi hoảng Quốc khánh là cảnh tổ được đợt bà bài bàn trường thành tế cơ sở,
đã tinh qua nhiều vị xí công tác, có năng lực kinh nghiệp trong xí dịch đàn và khoảng những nhả nước.
Đồng chiến luôn khoảng thành tốt mọi nịp bộ được rau, giết dệ bộ trong với cảnh hiện nay,
mong được chỉ sáng cạnh tổng các chính quyền và nhân dân các tranh tổng đình đạng sơn,
nữ lưu khóc cuộc nhanh những tịch hại sau bảo lúc gây ra, nghiên cứu kỳ các tế luận của bộ chiến trị về nước cơ trứ lựa hoạt động
bộ bộ máy chiến khuyền địa phương thái cấp, đảm bảo thông xuất thiệu lực vệ quảng.
Ông khoảng Quốc khánh, sinh nghiệm hại thành sĩnh năm rử chiến trăm sâu chiến,
dân tổng thái, quay ờ sả yên trâu tình xe lá, chứ môn được vụ khiến sĩ kinh tế, cao các vĩ hợp chính trị.